si vous voulez rajouter deux écrans à
votre PC portable regardez comment ça se
passe vous avez une boîte qui monte ça
s'appelle mobile pixel donc là vous avez
votre écran principal votre PC puis tout
ce qui vient se rajouter autour avec
deux écrans alors je vous explique vous
venez le brancher directement un écran
ici en USB C et le deuxième également en
usb-c alors ça vient prendre deux ports
USB C et ça se plie très facilement vous
le prenez comme ça vous venez les
glisser à l'intérieur ils viennent là et
ensuite vous n'avez plus qu'à venir le
replier et vous le voyez vous avez un
petit stand ici vous le prenez vous
l'enlevez vous êtes partis ce truc là
c'est assez marrant et lorsqu'on veut
l'ouvrir on fait exactement la même
chose on vient relever et ouvrir son PC
c'était monté derrière on met le petit
stand et on vient tirer d'un côté et de
l'autre vous avez hop là vos petits
moniteur et vous venez les mettre comme
ça tout ça c'est marrant alors il y a
différentes tailles qui existent là on
est sur un format 16 9 à priori ça tente
peut-être plus à du 18 9 m et vous
l'avez également avec un format qui est
un peu plus grand ici c'est mobile pixel
qui fait ça je crois d'ailleurs ça
pourrait vous botter si ça vous
intéresse il y a un sens pour vous ou
pas est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'augmenter la taille de votre
ordinateur portable c'est largement plus
épais mais sur le coup ça peut rendre
des services dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires